a wave of cocaine may be about to hit
the United States we showed you the
record Coco growth in Colombia yesterday
that's the raw ingredient in cocaine
cocaine production surged 37% in
Colombia between 2015 and 2016 much of
it is ultimately bound for the United
States Manuel Bojorquez went inside an
Operations Center tracking the drugs on
the ocean is that a Coast Guard
stationed in Miami Beach
Manuel good morning good morning the
u.s. stopped for metric tons of cocaine
in the eastern Pacific this past weekend
alone now the task force that found
those drugs is warning more are on the
way it's got to be like watching an
approaching storm it is I talked about
it is really an approaching tsunami of
cocaine getting ready to hit global
market
Coast Guard Admiral Christopher Tom nee
is the director of joint interagency
task force South the western hemispheres
nerve center for tracking drug
traffickers it's based in Key West
Florida where tourists visiting the
islands famed southernmost point seemed
largely unaware of what's happening
daily on the other side of the fence
that way a lot of stuff at the boat
looks like keep my feet up it's washed
out there yet from here an alphabet soup
of government agencies military branches
and 17 different nations work together
to find track and target drug
traffickers where they're most
vulnerable out on the high seas when
they're hundreds of miles away from
shore these traffickers have no place to
run they have no place to hide they're
out in plain sight these are the paths
that are taken for these drugs moving
into the United States and other parts
of the world absolutely as you see where
the lines get really thick if you were
to break this up you're really talking
thousands of events that we monitor last
year how much of that are you able to
stop very little three out of every four
events that we have awareness of we have
not no asset to go after they're getting
through they're getting through
we need more ships we need more aircraft
as it is the bottom line ships like the
Coast Guard Cutter James which we
visited on its way to the eastern
Pacific our last patrol we were able to
bring six
Dean tons of cocaine back it was worth
about 420 million dollars Wow nearly
enough to pay for this ship and now is
just in about a 45 day period now we're
gonna go into the combat Information
Center Captain Mark Fedor commands the
most sophisticated ship in the Coast
Guard's fleet we have a lot of different
sensors that can tell us what's going on
around us so we'll issue the orders to
launch the helicopter to launch the
small boats and then we vector them into
those targets that's one of the rounds
that we use right there armed
helicopters are key to the endgame
flying low alongside go-fast boats many
times at night to shoot out the engines
you can see on this side here the entry
point where a sniper round has gone in
and this has been very effective
technique but the smugglers have
developed techniques of their own like
Bigfoot Bigfoot is what we term a
self-propelled semi submersible these
low-profile semi submersibles are harder
to spot and carry tons more cocaine
probably a week does not go by that we
don't have a report somewhere throughout
the region of these of these types of
vessels on the water
last year the task force at an all-time
record stopping 285 metric tons of
cocaine but it's only a fraction of the
total flow it's very frustrating for the
men and women of this task force knowing
we could be doing so much more but it
really comes down to a series of choices
how much do we want to make this a
priority ultimately their goal is to
dismantle the trafficking networks which
can move anything not just drugs but
because of aging ships and aircrafts the
task force may have even fewer resources
next year Nora well great reporting
Manuel Bojorquez there thank you so much